hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
early on in being in time in sections 3
& 4 you're going to see Martin Heidegger
using a terminology that I think for
many people can be rather confusing in
part because he is relying upon a
distinction between the on tick and the
ontological and Germany on tuition on
Tolo geisha that he doesn't clearly
demarcate he doesn't come even close to
defining what these terms are meant to
signify just that there's a difference
between them and he seems to assume that
his reader will already be rather
conversant with them now most readers
are not so it's natural to get a little
bit confused at this point and say what
exactly is he trying to do with this and
so in these two chapters let's
disentangle them apart from each other
and then see what the the different
things that he talks about how they fit
it and with these it gets a little bit
more complicated in the fact that he
talks about design or you know human
being understood in the way that the
being in time is analyzing it as being
ontic ontological so so it gets even
more confusing there so let's start with
the distinction itself we have antic and
we have ontological both are coming from
the same basic root to own which is you
know a being or or being in Greek and we
get ontological from that own host right
you know the logical some sort of
studies as Heidegger would say an
interpretation of the the object which
is being or or a kind of being or
entities and how are these different
from each other so when we're talking
about the antic what we mean are the
concrete plain facts the things we can
observe about beings what it is that
makes those beings what they are how we
can describe them how we experience them
you know this can be the surface level
but this can also be what we might call
their deeper nature as described by the
various Sciences or disciplines and
there's all sorts of ways that we can
look at being you can look at me for
example in terms of history you can look
at me in terms of mere physiology which
then I guess we would connect with
biology you can look at me in terms of
physics as a I move around and you know
the blood circulates through my body
there's all these different ways in
which we can observe things and we say
that we get to deeper and deeper levels
so if you're doing you know some sort of
neurobiological study of my my brain
presumably we're getting at things that
you you can't normally know without all
of this technology and equipment and the
apparatus of the science to help us out
but that's still ontic so things like
for example brain states purely on tech
as far as Heidegger is concerned it's
things you can observe the ontological
has to do with the deeper structure of
being or if you like you can use his
term existence it's important that if
you do talk about existence that you
understand what he actually means by
that so let's let's remind ourselves
very quickly of what he has in mind and
and bringing up this term he says that
here we go we call the very being who
which design can relate in one way or
another and somehow always does relate
existence so existence is not a single
being it's not just a range of beings it
is
continual like engagement with being and
and beings so back to ontological when
we're trying to map out and and thereby
to interpret the deeper structures of
beings and being in general or being the
being of beings right the interpreting
the being of beings then we're engaged
with the ontological it's very tempting
for some people to try to associate this
with just the particular and the
universal or the general I wouldn't do
that
many universals fit inland the the antic
and the ontological although it is about
you know the totality of being
eventually it also has to do with our
own existence not just our happening to
be in existence but how we engage with
these these things that Heidegger is
going to call world being in the world
and time or a temper allottee that's
getting a little bit ahead of us but
that gives you a glimpse into what he's
talking about here and we might make a
distinction if we think about time this
is this book is being in time Heidegger
is going to carry out an extended and
very brilliant analysis of temporality
and he's trying to do that in an
ontological way right a way that
actually tries to get at the being of
beings not just what that being is but
how it's related to other beings going
beyond what the other disciplines or
Sciences can provide just we can also
think of time is something that we just
measure or even dole out to other people
for example as I'm shooting this video
right now because of the peculiarities
of this camera that I'm shooting with I
can see that were at a certain mark and
I can see that the seconds slipping by
all right that's that's purely on tech
my experience of time passing that can
be more ontological so hopefully that
makes a little bit of
this is something that you have to sort
of work your way through and keep
applying and keep applying and keep
applying and ask yourself is this
ontological or is this antic now
fortunately Heidegger in these two
sections is going to tell us quite a bit
about things that are on tick or things
that are ontological he starts out by
talking about the ontological priority
of the question of being and then the
next section is going to be the antic
priority of the question of being so
already we've got the two different
modes here being used and he tells us
being is always the being of a being the
totality of beings can become the field
where particular areas of knowledge are
exposed and delimited and and these are
what we call the sciences or the
disciplines and he's got some very
interesting reflections that we'll talk
about
elsewhere about Sciences exploring their
basic concepts and insofar as they do
that they actually move from the merely
antic into the ontological when they
start to say well what is biology really
about what are we doing as biologists
they are now engaged in an
interpretation of their own discipline
and ideally its history and its
activities and that takes them from you
know mere observation and theory
production or things like that into
something else
now Heidegger is going to go on in this
section 3 and tell us that we have
ontology x' now what isn't an ontology
this is some sort of interpretation of
beings in terms of being and and it's
usually going to be done in terms of
some sort of representative or typical
conception of being so for example
because this is very abstract right it
might be difficult to grasp if you think
about people who
understand the entire world in terms of
what is quantifiable and what can be
operationalized through algorithms so a
sort of very technological and a late
modern technological way of approaching
things there you've got an
interpretation of being which is the
being of beings everything can be turned
into an algorithm everything can be
understood in terms if you know
algorithms decision procedures and
mathematical constructs right and we go
on and on and on we can talk about other
ways of doing that as well
now Heidegger tells us that ontology can
be understood in its broadest sense
without reference to specific
ontological directions and tendencies
that is it's not just about say religion
or not just about which is about you
know the relation to the divine and not
just about history not just about the
physical sciences not just about human
beings understood as rational agents say
in economics but ontology taken in his
broadest sense he says this is more
original than the antek inquiry of the
positive sciences but he cautions us it
remains naive and opaque if the leaves
of the being of beings leaves the
meaning of being in general undiscussed
so what do we have to do we have to turn
to a particular actually not a
particularly general kind of being that
is actually related to other beings in a
rather unique way and that is what he's
calling design and we are design right
so he says all ontology remains blind if
it has not previously clarified the
meaning of being so now we turn to that
in this next section so here he brings
up the ontic ontological he says
the antique distinction of design lies
in the fact that it is ontological now
what does that mean
does that mean that we by our very
nature possess a kind of depth and
richness that other beings don't have
yes that is part of it and that's
something that that's a long-standing
part of at least certain philosophical
traditions when we make a distinction
between the human being of the human
person and the rest of the universe
sometimes we differentiate the animals
off as Heidegger will actually do in
this way and we said that belongs over
there and there are many interpretations
of this you know from Plato to Aristotle
to the medievals to Descartes to modern
you know scientific ways of looking at
these but Heidegger is telling us that
we're on to Cle distinguished that means
we are distinguished from other beings
in that this is part of our very nature
by what by the fact that this be in its
being this being is concerned about its
very being we have a kind of reflexivity
and it's not necessarily a cognitive
reflexivity this is integral to human
consciousness that we are concerned with
the very meaning of our own being
we are the animal who says not just I'm
a dog but am I a good dog
you know the master says good dog good
dog that does the dog actually question
and say am I really a good dog we do
that we do that in a myriad different
ways not just about good but about all
sorts of other things is my life an
authentic one am I on the right track
all of these sorts of things are ways in
which we can question our being even
involved with have I got matters right
am i part of some big you know
experiment or hallucination
where I'm getting things wrong all of
those open up a ontological depth to us
that does have to be understood very
often in antic dimensions but is
to logical now he says the antic
distinction of design lies in this fact
that it is on to logical and after this
he's going to keep on using this this
locution antek ontological to talk about
that the fact that we are grounded
we are rooted in our very antic aspects
of existence I am this tall I am wearing
this I am shooting this video at
such-and-such a time on a Thursday all
of those matters are antic they root me
in the here and now and yet there's a
more beyond that so he goes on and he
tells us to be ontological does not yet
mean to develop ontology we as human
beings are continually engaged both on
tickly and ontological e with the world
with being and with ourselves whether we
realize it or not whether we acknowledge
it or not and the goal of being in time
this entire work is to develop what
Heidegger is calling a fundamental
ontology another term that he has for
this at this point in his career is a
existential analysis of design but it's
connected with these things like time
the world human nature all of these
great metaphysical or as he will say
ontological topics so he he goes on and
he says ontology x' which have beings
other than design as their theme are
going to be founded and motivated in the
on text structure of design itself what
does all that mean
so this goes back to that notion that
ontology is that are not taking design
as their starting point human human
person or subjectivity or however you
want to conceive of it at this at this
point that if they're not taking that
this kind of being the being that can be
concerned about its own being as it's
starting point they are actually going
to
look to some other domain and they are
going to thereby get some things right
but other things wrong great example of
this would be the contemporary
fascination that people have for neuro
everything right neuroscience
neurolinguistics neuroethics neuro this
neuro that neuro criminology you know
and all of this is really based in a
very very antic conception of things
where all we really are our brains and
the brains relations with other things
mediated through the nerves and and you
know our senses and all of that sort of
thing it doesn't I mean the neuro
scientific approach to things it's very
narrowing and many of its proponents
don't really see that they think I've
got the stone that interprets everything
I've got the one way to make sense out
of all of our issues we can get get rid
of a lot of you know classic
philosophical problems and Heidegger
would say they're starting from the
wrong starting point if their goal is to
truly understand the human being in
relation to the world instead what we
need to do is a fundamental ontology by
taking design as the theme for our
ontology now he does say one other thing
that's very interesting towards the end
of this says the roots of the
existential analysis for their part are
ultimately existense ciel which is a way
of saying as he does immediately they
are antic so we never like lapsed into
some purely abstract or transcendental
study that leaves us the person who is
engaged in the study entirely behind or
treats are our peculiarities our
concrete existence as mere facts that we
don't have to pay any
- no we are antic ontological our access
to the ontological is going to be in
part mediated through the antic and so
there's going to be a constant back and
forth we actually need to take into
account both of these dimensions so
hopefully this gives you if not a
perfect clarification of the distinction
between antic and ontological at least
some starting points so as you go to the
rest of being and time
what Heidegger is saying will make more
sense
you